what it is it's fan mail Friday okay
speed round we're not messing around all
right we'll start with Kennedy and work
our way around to the judge all right
what animal would you want to cuddle
with knowing that it won't hurt you oh
like a hippopotamus but I know it'll
hurt me it promises it won't oh then I
would definitely snuggle with a hippo
those things are so cute I don't know
like a big cat I I don't know yeah a
lion right isn't it yeah a hippo hippo a
goat because I spend the whole time
saying look at Jud that's weird yeah
you're the goat you want to hold the
goat I get it I'd be a killer whale I'd
like like to be small for once all right
quick Kennedy what song lyric has struck
you throughout your life o good question
MTV background no 9in Nails uh you could
have it all my Empire of dirt I will let
you down I will make you hurt nice is it
beautiful uh free bird skard I love the
Johnny Cash cover of that and a cry and
the whole backstory to that's awesome
speed round um I woman hear me roar and
voices carry shut up I love that song I
had a biggest crush lady there we go all
right face here we go when was the last
time you were at a movie theater and
what movie did you see uh I saw
Oppenheimer nice oh nice we went to see
um uh Napoleon it stunk it stunk we
don't have time for that speed round
terrible uh Barbie Barbie that's a lie
all right what was your favorite store
to shop in growing up
Nordstrom I don't like I don't know
Walmart I don't know Forever 21 you're
there was no Walmart when you were
growing up ards ards mine was news ber
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else